you know I cannot find mention of
another movie called spy that's [ __ ]
weird do we think spy would be the title
of the fifth movie ever made in the
history of cinema we think they'd be
like we have to call it doctor know why
because spy already exists this is the
60s combined others thought it was weird
that in 2015 we finally have a movie
called spy
spy so spies a Melissa McCarthy comedy
directed by Paul fig the director of
bridesmaids which pretty much made
Melissa McCarthy Melissa McCarthy as we
know her so inspired my list McCarthy's
like the tech support every spy out
there and this agency has someone in
their ear like oh hey I can see the
infrared oh there's three guys down the
hall while you know they're monitoring
them through satellites and whatnot and
super sexy super evil Rose Byrne with
some really impressive resting [ __ ]
gets the identities of all the spies out
there so they're like we need to send
someone in the field to find this nuke
that's going on the black market but it
has to be someone that no one knows
about so they send Melissa McCarthy now
is a Melissa McCarthy spy comedy and I
could say with confidence that I have
seen it all when it comes to Melissa
McCarthy I had actually become sick of
her which is why to my surprise I
actually enjoyed spy it showed me that
Melissa McCarthy can be Melissa McCarthy
without being Tammy she can be funny she
can be likable but she can also be mean
a lot of the comedy in Finn's movie is
some back and forth it's just really
insulting and almost angry but it's not
hateful II angry it ultimately feels
like the Comedy Central Roast and
there's a progression of her character
she's not always angry she's not always
snarky and funny she starts out really
timid you know she's not really
confident by the end she's Melissa
McCarthy as we kind of know her it's
always good to see your main character
get confidence throughout a movie I just
kind of need to get a bonus attached to
it which is some really solid burns from
her Jason Statham's in the movie Jason
Statham was really good too he and
McCarthy have some good back and forth I
like that Jason Statham just monologuing
ultimately there was this monologue he
had I thought he was gonna overdo it and
he kind of started too until he didn't
anymore because I just enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of it ultimately has his monologue
this pretty much he's talking about
himself but it's like Chuck Norris jokes
but him I can't deny I was laughing my
ass off and movie had good action in it
too which I found surprising usually in
a spy comedy people are kind of bumbling
they get the job done somehow but it's
like I'm here for the laughs and comedy
trip and someone to like you know fall
over and they somehow accidentally save
the day but it's not like that Melissa
McCarthy actually kicks some ass in this
movie Jason Statham kicks ass there's
some solid spy as kicker II going on
among the last movie super violent -
yeah it's rated R there are a lot of
f-bombs in this movie and there's like
some blood real like it's not like a
gorge it's not like Kill Bill there were
some hits in this movie I didn't expect
that no deep down in the bones of this
movie like to its core it's a pretty
cliche spy movie you've seen this plot a
zillion
you have seen it all I promise you even
if you don't watch a lot of spy movies
you've seen this plot guys in the end
I'm baffled to say I enjoy the [ __ ] out
of spy it's like a Melissa McCarthy
resurgence for me I was ready to just go
I'm done with these movies this this
[ __ ] is like Call of Duty it's the same
thing every time but she's funny I enjoy
the back-and-forth in the movie it's an
exciting enough movie there's some solid
kick-ass harine spy I walked out having
a good time with it but in the end I
will say Spy is a good time if you're
drunk ya know it's a party just kidding
spies actually a good time no alcohol
required by just kidding I would buy spy
on blu-ray the reality of the situation
is it's a funny movie it's an enjoyable
movie why do you need a rating I'm not
talking to everybody out there but I am
certainly talking to some people in the
comments section of my entourage review
I will say this if two completely
separate movies two completely different
movies are made in two completely
different fashions for two completely
different purposes that get the same
rating from a rating system created by
me that was made as a [ __ ] you to rating
systems it's a farce it's a faux rating
system I am not calling these movies
equals they're different movies so
review matters the rating doesn't the
movie is either worth watching or it's
not just listen to the review don't
judge everything on the stamp that's the
writing the fact is among my rating
system I have six different ratings
that's six different brackets that
people want to put movies in so implying
every movie in a bracket is as good as
every movie in that bracket every movie
in that rating has to say there are six
different variables of how good a movie
is period across all movies that is
stupid and that's why ratings are stupid
and I hate them that's why we're here we
have to be here because at a point when
I started to think maybe I should just
do away with my rating system because a
couple of cheeseheads in the comments
section and just had to be said again
this doesn't pertain to all of you most
of you out there are beautiful wonderful
fans and you're a lot of fun and I love
having all of you there are some loud
[ __ ] bag dip shits have to just scream
in the comments section and just ruin
the fun so it has to be said as
literally the last I will say of it rant
over rant done alright so spy have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more